foreign
hi I'll be talking about the CSS modules
work that we've been doing in Google
Plus module is a problem
that's not just applicable to Google or
Google plus it's a problem
that's faced by all very large
applications that have lots of features
so this is just a sampling of some of
the top level pages on Google Plus and
within each of these Pages we have tons
of features and lots of features add up
to a lot of JavaScript and a lot of CSS
and as you can see from these numbers
here we have a ton of CSS and so we have
a problem to solve
again and this is not the only problem
we do have the problem of big CSS and
and we want our initial page load to be
super fast but in addition a problem
we've been facing a lot over the last
year has been that kind of broken uis
a lot of our CSS is manually curated in
build files and this was this is brittle
and it's prone to reordering so this is
the second problem that we're trying to
fix
so module systems is primarily solving
the problem of size but building a
module system is much simpler if you
absolutely had no shared code in your
site so let's say every page of your
site is completely independent and
doesn't share any code at all then it's
fairly straightforward to build a module
system every page becomes its own module
and you load it as you go but in reality
though we do have a ton of shared code
and if you don't have any shared code
then you're definitely doing something
wrong because Styles should be shared
across your site
so building this dependency system
turned out to be a big win on its own
it's vastly improved the CSS development
experience because now we can rely on
the framework to ensure the correct
Cascade ordering and developers don't
have to keep fighting specificity
anymore
so this project is a work in progress we
haven't completely launched all of
Google Plus yet we have launched modules
to several pages on our site and we've
seen significant improvements in CSS
size
and the preprocessor we use internally
in Google is called closure style sheets
and internally we call this GSS so if I
accidentally say GSS in this talk I
really mean CSS
so the step one to build an effective
module system is to know what the shared
code is
and this is not always trivial to
identify
um you might sometimes you might notice
you know the button and a menu look
similar but it's not easy to see exactly
what is similar
so we can at least start with a very
obvious let's start with the exact same
UI elements that keep repeating over and
over again and these are things like
buttons and icons and what's famously
called the media object and we have a
ton of these repeating patterns in
Google Plus
so Google Plus is a social network and
the primary thing on the main page are
these posts which are contained in what
are called cards and every post has the
same characteristics every post has an
icon with the name of the person posting
it has buttons for upporting and
resharing and it has comment activity in
addition on the top left is what we call
the share box if you wanted to share
something with your network this is
where you would start typing
this is a completely different page it's
my profile page and you can see that the
top right card is different but again
the common theme Here is there are posts
and the posts have the same
characteristics and again we see the
share box
and you can see the common elements
outlined in red
yet another page on Google Plus this is
called the Community page it's a forum
for people of similar interest here it's
photography and again it has unique
elements like the left panel and the
right card
but again posts and sharebox
photos page
at first glance it looks completely
different but if you look on the right
panel you see the same repeating
components again so you get the point we
have a ton of shared components all over
our site but this is not all in addition
to this we have lots of shared Styles
across Google Plus and these are things
like fonts and colors and layouts and
then in addition to that we have lots of
common Styles across all of Google and
these are things like buttons check
boxes dialogues menus which this is so
that as you navigate different Google
products like map or search you get a
somewhat consistent look and feel
and by the way everything I showed you
so far is developed by completely
different teams so we have these
somewhat competing goals of all these
teams wanting to split their code by
project boundary but we want them to
share all of these common Styles so this
is all the more reason why we need a
dependency system
because we want a systematic framework
and not rely on developer discipline
so we saw how the home page and the
Community page share some code like in
this case they should they share the
code for posts and sharebox in addition
they have their own unique elements we
definitely want to write all of the
shared code only once we want to
download it only once to the browser
and we want to download the minimum
possible CSS
so let's consider the larger problem of
code that's downloaded on the browser
and this is not just CSS but includes
everything the browser needs to render
the page including templates and
JavaScript so for the homepage we've
already seen we need code to render
posts render the share box and other
home page specific elements
so our one of our main goals here is
when we first visit the home page we
want the page to be super fast just load
the minimum code needed to render just
that page and nothing more and then
later when we go and visit the Community
page or some other page then
incrementally load code just for the
features needed for that
now it turns out there is already a
solution for this in JavaScript and it's
called JavaScript modules and it solves
exactly this problem of incremental
download and any JavaScript developers
in the group might be familiar with AMD
or common JS and last year my co-workers
from Google Malta and John unveiled the
open source Google module server
however there is absolutely no solution
for this in CSS yet
and the question is can we potentially
use the same solution
there is a catch though in CSS we have
the problem of safety so in this example
when I go visit the Community page after
the home page if I'm not careful about
how I write my code the styles that I
load later can override the Styles I've
loaded earlier so it's possible that I
break the UI for the home page so now we
have this additional goal that as we
incrementally load CSS we want
absolutely no regressions on previously
shown pages
so if you're coming to the conclusion
that CSS is not as simple we have the
safety challenge that I already
mentioned in addition we know that we
have a ton of shared code we want a
dependency system but CSS doesn't have a
notion of dependencies
and almost every other language seems to
have this and this is you require in
common.js or Import in Java and python
so how do we depend on what we need and
how do we depend only on what we need
a recap of our goal here is just deliver
the minimum amount of CSS do it
incrementally and safely and the
challenges here are bundling the CSS
with its dependencies downloading it as
needed and safely composing it so we are
essentially saying we need a module
system
because bundling CSS adapts is really
what a dependency system does and
downloading and composing is what an
assembly and serving system does
so let's look at each of these
challenges starting with the first one
so we Define a CSS module as a bundle of
CSS that supports the page of our site
and is downloaded together
and we've already identified CSS shared
code and dependencies and these are
things like CSS from the shared
components fonts and colors that are
expressed typically as constants and in
addition we have a lot of common CSS
libraries and these are in our case
these are Google wide styles
so let's stipulate up front that the
naive Solutions don't work for our case
we cannot just use a CSS at import on
every page we visit because this would
just duplicate download all of that
shared code and you've seen we have a
ton of shared code
in addition we want to include only what
we need
for example different pages use
different variants of the share box I
showed you now if the profile page wants
a bit one wants one out of seven
variants it should only include that one
and nothing more
in another non-solution for us is we
cannot take every single style that's
shared across our entire site and bundle
this together into a giant shared depth
module this module is going to get very
large and unmaintainable very quickly
so let's start out with figuring out how
to express dependencies in each of these
cases
with shared components because we write
Styles in a completely separate style
sheet how do we even know which CSS
belongs to each of these
while we don't know exactly which CSS
belongs to this we do know what
templates are needed to render those
components and we know what JavaScript
is needed to make them interactive and
those things the templates and the
JavaScript can in turn point us to the
CSS that they pull in
so essentially what we are saying is
um let's bundle template JavaScript and
CSS into
components and this starts to sound a
little bit like a web components
so this idea is similar to Nicole's CSS
Legos
which is identify shared widgets create
reusable groups of CSS
the additional concept we're bringing
here is we want to bundle templates and
JavaScript together and create
self-contained components and
essentially if you want the framework to
do all of the heavy lifting and not rely
on developer discipline because the top
priority for developers is to launch
their features
so to create these self-components
Express dependencies from the template
to the CSS and from JavaScript to the
CSS and we've created Syntax for both of
these
so for the templates case we use closure
templates in Google Plus
and we've come up with this required CSS
annotation that you can just add to your
template pointing to the GSS namespace
and similarly we have a an annotation
that we use in our JavaScript for the
same purpose and this can just as well
be expressed with AMD syntax
so at the end of this after we have
identified these components bundle them
together and we are expressing
dependencies of that at the end of this
we have
a component dependency graph for this
page
and once we do this across our entire
site we have a complete component
dependency graph
the second type of dependencies we
identified are things like fonts and
colors and these are typically expressed
as constants for us
there's established Syntax for this in
most preprocessors this is at Import in
SAS and we use closure style sheets and
our syntaxes provide and require
and this fits in really well
with our CSS dependency graph so let's
say the profile page wants a separate
set of constants from the home page it
can depend on just those cost constants
so this is an example of the provide
required Syntax for constants so in this
case we have a profile base
name GSS name CSS namespace that is
exporting a constant for profile update
background color and if something else
wants to use that constant all it has to
do is say at require and use the
constant
so now we are expanding our CSS
dependency graph to include these Common
forms and colors and essentially all of
our constants and mixins become part of
this dependency graph
we haven't covered what we're doing with
common CSS libraries yet but we'll come
back to that soon
so moving on to the next challenge here
how do we safely compose the CSS in the
browser
but to set the background for this I
have to reiterate kind of the basic
points of CSS which is order and
specificity see CSS is inherently order
dependent if you have base Styles and
you have overrides for these Styles the
base Styles must be ordered before the
overwrites and specificity can Trump
order
so in this example if I have a div
wrapping hello world text and I have two
classes on it blue and red with the
colors blue and red the hello world is
going to show up in blue
and the reason for this is that the
Cascade order dictates the Styles
applied not the classes in HTML
however if I added yet another class
um to this and added the additional
class in my CSS file that changes the
color to Red this is because I have just
bumped up the specificity
um off the off the red class
and in general this is not a great way
of overriding
because every time you wanted to
overwrite something if you're going to
bump up the specificity then you're
essentially fighting it the neck on the
next override and this is famously
called the specificity Wars
so if you generally want to use the
Cascade to dictate Styles and not
specificity
so thanks to the work that Nicole has
done on object-oriented CSS there is a
body of guidelines and we've found these
to be really accurate from our own GSS
development experience we want to
minimize the selectors we have we want
to reuse as much as possible we want to
keep specificity low and we want to have
rules of the same strength and we want
the Cascade order
to override Styles not specificity
but ideally we want our framework to do
all of this for us the framework should
enable us to create simple selectors and
rules of equal strength
um and and cover and basically correctly
order the Cascade so the developers are
not fighting specificity
so let's take the concrete example of a
button we have a button which has some
common Styles and different pages
want to override in a slightly different
way and let's say for this example they
want to change the color in for all
these different cases
there's many ways to override styles and
each one has its pros and cons and we're
going to quickly look at some of the
common ways to override styles
um
the typical way to do this is you should
ideally be extending the standard button
class with your own context-specific
button class
and often programmers might start out
with a compound selector for this so you
would write profile button dot standard
button
and we've already said that this is not
the ideal way to do this as it's prone
to clashes if you further if you want
further overrides of that same style
let's say you want different styles in
profile whether if that button appears
in the header versus the sidebar
descendant selectors is another way to
do this
here and this is definitely better than
compound selectors
but to some extent you may be tying your
CSS to a predefined HTML structure
you might use tools to do this
mix-ins are a pretty standard thing in
most preprocessors and if you use a
mix-in
it would automatically expand the Styles
in line so you're essentially getting
rid of the standard button class
and the problem with this is now you are
duplicating all of these Styles in each
context and we've already said we don't
want any duplication
yet another way to do this is use the
SAS extend with a placeholder and this
compiles to something like this
and this is a vast improvement over
mixins
however this is not our ideal solution
with a dependency graph because now we
have this one rule which has all of
these feature specific selectors tied
together and now this rule is going to
show up in some shared module in our
dependency graph and ideally we just
want to keep feature specific code in
separate modules
and finally a way to do this is to
Simply write the overriding Styles keep
standard Button as it is and it's
already provided in our shared Library
anyway and let every context just add
its own style
but here now we need to rely on the
correct Cascade order
this is in fact our preferred way to
override Styles in Google Plus and we
have a Syntax for this which is provide
and require
so if profile button needs to be ordered
f after the standard button all it has
to do is at require the standard button
so we essentially
expanding the semantics of at require to
include ordering now and we've
considered some Alternatives here like
expressing this ordering in JavaScript
and templates and this wasn't as pretty
because first of all they ever do it in
both places and now there is CSS
ordering semantics in templates and in
JavaScript
and we also like the solution because it
meets our requirements we minimize
selectors we have rules of equal
strength
we still haven't covered how to handle
style overrides for components yet
so first of all
I want to demonstrate that using
components with a dependency graph
actually guarantees correct Cascade
order as well
so let's say I have many widgets on my
site and they both they all want to use
a common
component like an icon
so this will basically map to some
dependency graph if we are using
components
and the Styles would show up in the
graph
and eventually we are going to flatten
this dependency graph into the Cascade
but we do we still preserve the order so
all the ordering the arrows that were
there in the previous graph are
preserved in this Cascade
and the framework gen will now create
the correct Cascade from this graph
we still haven't said exactly how we are
overriding Styles though and well the
two ways we do this most often in our
case are either using additional classes
or descendant selectors
um
if the component is going to be mostly
overridden in almost every context it's
used then it's better well we think it's
better to Simply add an additional class
and this means that the overriding
context has to plumb the additional
class into the components template and
this but this is fine because it's
essentially exposing an API for the
override
uh the other way we do this is with
descendant selectors
and with and this is still fine because
we're not really tying this to some
predefined HTML structure per se we are
we are tying it to a context
so so far we've covered the types of CSS
dependencies in our system
and we've shown you the syntax we use to
express these dependencies
and we've shown you the oh how to
override each category
and we've shown you what the Cascade
order
so now we've covered all our categories
of depths and we essentially have a
complete CSS dependency graph that
includes all of our shared Styles and
components fonts and colors and the
Google common CSS libraries Etc
so this cupboard our dependency system
we have namespaces we have a way of
expressing dependencies
so now we move on to our assembly and
serving system
so I've already touched on how modules
get flat well how a dependency graph
gets flattened to a Cascade
and here
um the only additional thing is that we
also identify modules so you're
identifying granular units of modules in
this graph
and then you compile the CSS to these
modules and then the modules get
translated into a Cascade
so a module is
a CSS grouping downloaded together and
we always download the dependencies for
every module that we load on the browser
and this is analogous to our notion of
JS modules
and so we're really trying to sort of
piggyback on the download system that we
already have for JS modules
now for serving it pretty much works in
the way you would expect
you have the Community page depends on
the modules for the sharebox and the
posts
and when you when it wants to render
those those modules in turn will pull in
all the other modules that they depend
on and so this will include your buttons
and your comments widgets and your fonts
and common Styles Etc
and then later on when we visit the home
page
we only
additionally download just the modules
needed for the home page because we
already have everything else
so the important point with this
download system is that it also ensures
safety so we we mentioned earlier how
you know late late at the later page has
the potential to override the styles of
a previous page and but here we don't
we've already solved this problem by
doing all of this hard work of creating
this dependency graph
so now
there is no question of Home paid Styles
overriding the Community page Styles
because all of their common dependencies
have already been downloaded
so in summary the system is solving both
of our original problems now
we're solving the problem that we our
initial bundle is really big and it's
really slow and we have manually curated
CSS that can get reordered and break our
UI
and these are some open source resources
we use closure style sheets and this has
our Syntax for at provide and network
wire and we use closure templates which
doesn't have our Syntax for require CSS
yet but we'll in the future
and that is all
thank you
foreign